that debate that I did in Qatar they
played this video that was like a bunch
of famous individuals that might be
accused of being toxically masculine in
one form or another and I was like okay
I understand that you have a problem
with the people that have just been held
up as potential role models for men
please tell me who you'd suggest instead
and it took 10 seconds in front of a
live audience of silence for him to say
my brother-in-law and I was like how
about somebody that we all know I think
it was a really important moment that
showed it is really hard to find a
positive image for what men could and
should be the strange thing is the
things that define masculinity we do
celebrate them but in women so when a
woman is like confident and loud and in
your face we love that if you say oh
yeah man confident to go get in Fierce
it's like oh no we don't like that it's
a shame because we don't seem to be
benefactors of the lessons of History
because this isn't the first time we've
pathologized agenda toxic masculinity is
just a modern equivalent of female
hysteria where we take female distress
and we pathologize it as something to be
treated and we subject them to this
crazy sort of experiments to fix the
problem and we're doing the same now we
see masculinity as a problem to be fixed